الفرقاطات الأمريكية
تتجه نحو أوكرانيا،
أطنان من الأسلحة الأمريكية
تهبط في أوكرانيا،
ورسيا تعلن ساعة الصفر وتحرك فوجاً من جنودها
تجاه أوكرانيا،
الغواصات النووية تحوم في الأرجاء،
إنها ليست نهاية العالم
بل هي مؤشرات لحرب عالمية ثالثة،
الوضع مكهرب لدى أقوى الدول في العالم
والجو ضبابي،
فهل كل تلك هي بوادر لحرب بين الغرب وروسيا؟..
في المقابل تصعيد سياسي غير مسبوق،
وهذه الدولة تتهم الأخرى بالتصعيد،
ومناورات عسكرية تعطي إشارات
باقتراب الحرب بين أمريكا والغرب من جهة
وروسيا وحلفائها من جهة أخرى،
فما هي النهاية يا ترى؟
....
روسيا تبدي قلقها من توسع حلف الناتو في أوكرانيا،
وتحشد جنودها على الحدود،
وأمريكا تضع جنودها على أهبة الاستعداد،
ما الذي يجري ياترى؟
..
المعطيات تقول إن روسيا تستعد لشن حرب على أوكرانيا
لاستعادتها كما كانت من قبل،
في زمن الاتحاد السوفييتي،
وهذا هو ما يخشاه الغرب أوكرانيا تماما،
وأي خوف هذا!!
هل هو الرعب من عودة الدب الروسي لأمجاده السوفييتية؟
فروسيا تريد من الغرب التعهد بعدم ضم أوكرانيا إلى حلف الناتو،
وعلى الرغم من أن الجانبين يجريان المفاوضات،
لكن بدون جدوى.
وما سيحدث بعد ذلك قد يعرض الهيكل الأمني لأوروبا بالكامل
للخطر. فعن أي خطر يتحدثون؟
...
في عام ٢٠١٤،
استولت روسيا على جزء من أوكرانيا ودعمت الانفصاليين
الذين بدأوا صراعاً في مناطق واسعة شرقي البلاد.
فيما سيطر الانفصاليون المدعومون من روسيا أيضا،
على مساحات شاسعة من الأراضي الشرقية لأوكرانيا،،،،،
لكن روسيا تنفي أي خطط لها ، فما الذي يجري؟
الذي يجري على الأرض هو محاولة روسيا
تحجيم أوكرانيا شيئا فشيئا لتأخذها إليها مرة واحده،
ومحاولة منع انضمامها للناتو أو تواجده على أرضها،،
والسؤال الآن أين أمريكا مما يجري؟
...
وزارة الدفاع الأميركية (البنتاغون)
أعلنت  أن قوة عديدها 8500 عسكري أميركي
وضعوا
في "حالة تأهب قصوى"
تحسبا لاحتمال نشرها تعزيزَ أي
تفعيل لقوة التدخل التابعة لحلف شمال الأطلسي
ردا على الأزمة الأوكرانية.
فبم توحي كل هذه التحشيدات؟
في المقابل، حشدت روسيا 100 ألف جندي
قرب الحدود الأوكرانية مثيرة المخاوف من مخطط
لغزو جارتها الموالية للغرب،
مما استدعى تحذيرات من دول الغرب.
فعن أي قوات نتحدث؟!!!
...
القوات المسلحة الروسية تطلق سلسلة جديدة
من المناورات بالقرب من أوكرانيا
وفي شبه جزيرة القرم التي ضمتها،
مع تدريبات تشمل 6 آلاف عنصر وطائرات مقاتلة
وقاذفات.
قائد القوات الروسية في جنوب روسيا،
يقول: إنها عملية "مشتركة"
تشمل خصوصا "سلاح الجو
ومضادات الطائرات وسفن أسطولَي البحر الأسود
وبحر قزوين".
تدريبات سلاح الجو هذه،
تشمل 60 مقاتلة وقاذفة في 4 مناطق
لا سيما شبه جزيرة القرم التي ضمتها روسيا في 2014
ردا على ثورة موالية للغرب في أوكرانيا.
ألا يكفي هذا لشن حرب طاحنة
تأكل الأخضر واليابس؟
..
أما الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
فقد أعلنت دعمها لأوكرانيا
بمساعدات تصل إلى ٢٠٠مليون دولار،
وتشمل المساعدات كذلك "
تجهيزات وذخائر لتعزيز القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية"
..
من جانبه حلف شمال الأطلسي يضع قوات احتياطية
في حالة تأهب، ويرسل سفنا ومقاتلات لتعزيز الدفاعات
في أوروبا الشرقية ضد الأنشطة العسكرية الروسية
على حدود أوكرانيا.
فهل صارت الحرب على الأبواب؟
وهل تدق هذه الدول طبول حرب عالمية ثالثة؟
سياسيا يحاول الفرنسيون والبريطانيون
الدخول في حوار مع روسيا لثنيها عن الغزو المتوقع،
مطلقين تحذيرا في الوقت ذاته أن أي تدخل عسكري
لروسيا في أوكراني ستكون خسائره الاقتصادية
قاسية جدا على جميع الأطراف، وماذا بعد؟١
...
في الأمم المتحدة أيضا ترى أمريكا وحلفاؤها
أن الإشارات الإيجابية من روسيا لن تكون إلا من خلال
سحب قواتها والتراجع الفوري من الحدود الأوكرانية
وبيلاروسيا أيضا،
لكن هذا لا يبدو واقعيا، فذلك يعني إعلان روسيا
هزيمتها أمام هذه الدول في نظر الروس، ،،،
(العقوبات)
في الغرب يتحدثون عن أقسى العقوبات
ففي حال قررت روسيا غزو أوكرانيا،
عليها أن تنتظر عقوبات قاسية وغير مسبوقة،
من بينها:
خفض مشتريات الغاز والنفط اللذين يشكلان
43% و20% من إمدادات الاتحاد الأوروبي،،
أيعقل هذا؟!!!
في الوقت ذاته تعتزم أمريكا منع المصارف الروسية
من استخدام الدولار، مما قد يوجه ضربة قاسية جدا
لاقتصاد روسيا.
....
بينما تحذر واشنطن من خطر شبح إحياء الحرب الباردة،
ترد موسكو بأن على الغرب والناتو أن لا يتوسع
في أوكرانيا والدول الحدودية، وبين هذا وذاك
تظهر حرب عالمية
قد تغير مجرى الأحداث في العالم،
فكيف ستكون نهاية هذه التوترات؟